all days that the country will never
forget exactly five years ago riots
swept English cities Trevor Reeves
looked on helplessly while his family
business burns to the ground now only
this building remains one of the old
handmade tiles from the store of the
roof of the store but what's lost will
never be replaced that drew a line under
that part of history no that was the
building that was remembered by
everybody is being Reeves it wasn't the
building we're in now even though this
was the original small part of it was
where it was started that was the bit
that people remember they're the gabled
roofs the lovely oval chimneys the
architecture the way with it it was a
wonderful building and you know people
remember it with very fond hearts it all
began here in London Marcus and his
friend Curtis hen Vil were among many
angered when their friend Mark Duggan
was killed by the police
come to the police station
basically demanding answers to when what
had been shot stood out there for six
hours with it to turn us away at her so
clear the streets
anger on the car ended up smashing it up
and everything kind of escalated from
there
Marcus knocks hook went to jail for his
role in the riots with a single act of
violence that has been described as the
start of all four days of rioting I mean
my fight was against the police
I understand like he wasn't wasn't me
work coming out to lose shot
if your personal where personal people
personal people a person entering
eventually they're gonna stand up to you
or delicately
know what we're gonna to do not know why
from when we're gonna sort outside of
the police station for six hours for
them to the entire time unaware I said
alright cool that's how you gonna do
with me whatever happens to me today I
don't care okay I was in Bangla me at my
point long it's striking how many people
here in Tottenham feel that the
frustration that initially triggered the
riots that deaths in police custody
years of suspicion towards the
authorities and a lack of opportunities
but still is present than ever at the
same time there's no denying people are
moving into this area in spite of its
reputation for unrest not least a
protest in front of this police station
it's changing and some would say being
gentrified since the riots the
government has made demolishing council
estates and replacing them with mixed
communities an explicit strategy to
prevent future disturbance the area
police commander for Tottenham during
the riots says that's now making things
look much more positive to see any event
like that was absolutely traumatic it
was devastating
that symbol of that burning bus I
thought toplin police station to see
cries to see officers who were fearful
you know it was a completely disturbing
image please Stephen time but that also
bought an equal amount of determination
that this cannot happen again we're
going to dig in we're going to work hard
we're going to build genuine
relationships and we're going to make
sure that prosperity comes back into
those areas but for many rising property
values mean the future of their
community is under threat that's causing
anger but could there be more riots
there's a possibility
but I'm not waiting for the rights to
happen again I understand like I'm
trying to make some sort of change you
get me to break that cycle our hash sky
knees